justin here with the game spot news
update we've recently heard that sony
has laid off an undisclosed number of
staff at three of its UK development
studios numerous people have been let go
from evolution studio guerrilla
cambridge and SCE London studio in a
statement Sony said that a recent
internal review triggered the need for
restructuring at the studios a statement
from Sony reads we've reviewed and
assessed all current projects and
decided to make some changes to some of
our European studios as a result of this
there will be a focus tree structure
within London studio gorilla Cambridge
studio and evolution studio to ensure
the Sony Computer Entertainment
worldwide studios is in the best
position to achieve their goals going
forward sony also added that the
previously delayed PlayStation 4 racing
game driveclub which is under
development at evolution studios is
unaffected by the layoffs gorilla
Cambridge has recently finished work on
the PS Vita shooter killzone mercenary
but it's unknown what title SCE London
is working on we'll be keeping track of
further developments at Gamescom but in
the meantime good luck to everyone
affected by this disappointing layoff
trend
you